So I promised you some properties.
There's a bunch of them.
One of them is that it's useful,
and that in particular,
it's useful for large state spaces.
And the reason that that works, right,
is I don't have to actually look at all
the states, do all the value
iteration for everything.
I basically just kind
of do it as I go along.
And I only visit the states
that I need to visit,
given where I happen to be in the world.
There are some downsides of this,
and one downside is,
depending upon just how much randomness
there is in your transition model,
you need lots of samples in
order to get a good q hat.
But you know what, that's true anyway.
If you have many, many, many,
many many, many states, then you're
going to have to do a lot of visiting
to figure out what's going on usually.
So, this is the sort of, I think it's
kind of intrinsic to the problem.
Now of course, if you don't have a lot
of states, you still end up generating
lots and lots of samples because
of the way Monte Carlo works.
Luckily there, it's relatively
inexpensive to do, in most cases,
at least,
most of the cases that we worry about.
And in the end, despite all that,
it has another good feature.
I really like this feature.
It's my favorite of its features,
is that the planning time
is actually independent of
the number of states that you have.
That's why it's useful for
large state spaces.
>> I see, I mean,
I guess if there's a lot of states,
do we have to expand like a fixed
percentage of them to know what to do?
>> Well sure, you have to.
That's how you're going to
generate your samples.
You're going to have to generate
lots of samples that way.
So yeah.
>> But then it's not independent of s?
>> Well, it is independent of s.
That's one of the cool things
about Monte Carlo Tree Search.
>> No, I know, but what I asked was,
so that means that as the state
space gets bigger, do we have to expand
a fixed percentage of the state space?
>> You said percentage, I'm sorry.
I didn't even turn that into percentage,
I'm sorry.
So the answer is no, because if you did,
it would depend upon
the number of states.
>> [LAUGH] Okay, but how could that be?
How could it be that the state
space gets bigger, and yet,
we don't have to look at very
much of it to know what to do?
>> Well, it's because you're
really only going through,
you're executing through the world.
And the trade off happens
in the other bullet,
which is the bad thing about MCTS.
>> It kind of reminds me of, like,
I don't know, election surveys.
It's probably not the right word.
But this sort of idea that you can
actually get an idea of how many
people are voting,
no matter how big the country is by
just surveying a fixed number of people.
>> Right, so long as they have
properties that are representative,
and so long as you can get a
representative sample of the states and
the actions, then you're good.
>> That's really interesting.
>> Right, now, of course, that's
going to depend, I mean, so to me,
what's going to drive that is going
to be how much randomness and
entropy there is in
the transition function.
>> I see.
>> Because if it's
completely deterministic,
you don't have to do
a lot of samples at all.
>> Yeah, that would make sense.
>> But
there's something else that drives how
expensive Monte Carlo Tree Search is,
which is the fourth bullet that I was
about to write down before you asked me
this complicated question,
which is that the running time.
>> Is independent of
the size of the state space.
>> It's independent in the sense
that it's exponential.
>> Wait, in the size of the state space?
>> It's exponential in
the affective horizon.
>> So you're saying it doesn't
matter how many states
are in the state space, but
it does matter how far into the future
you need to look to make a decision?
>> Yes, and of course, the tree
itself is growing exponentially.
[LAUGH] So you're going to
need to have more and more and
more of those samples to make it work.
Actually, due to Kearns and
his colleagues,
we actually know exactly
what the running time is.
It is big O of the size
of your action space,
which makes sense because
that's your branching factor.
And I need another variable here.
Let's call it x,
which is how many steps you're
going to actually run the thing for.
And that loop that I did
before raised to the horizon.